what do you got d our first submission
is from Amanda Frick is there a cat
Amanda [ __ ] what's a white to you and I
have a debate club topic for you I want
to know if you guys had to spend the
rest of your life with a woman who could
a never laugh or B never orgasm which
would you prefer and I'm talking like no
faking it no giggling nothing like which
what you're you go be able to handle I
love you guys Gang Gang buzz buzz what's
up girl buzz buzz every I'll be doing
that I'll show uh use your stupid dude
they need to [ __ ] change his battery
they do it's us no they do we have a
staff of 9700 gas staff of 97 gets paid
a dollar I'm sick of it
[ __ ] sick of it so she was saying a
girl who can't orgasm or she doesn't
laugh mm-hmm go ahead dude kick it off I
would say a girl who can't orgasm and
that's pretty much most of my
ex-girlfriends that's and it's not their
fault either
and I'll say good game you know dude I
have a good dick shut up the short day I
just don't have the the agility and the
gamesmanship I think behind my Weiner
isn't now you got that letter I got that
[ __ ] you know I got that big baby
Glen Davis you know what I'm saying like
he comes into the game every now minute
he's a real hitter you know but then
also he's not afraid to you know the
time not he'll also fist fist fight a
dude over the counter at a Hampton Inn
yeah what I'm saying so I get caught
slang and drugs it's like just makes bad
decisions or [ __ ] awesome decisions
but just you know sometimes he just you
know he won the sixth man then in the
seventh man award then eighth man and at
a certain point he was just he won like
the 700th man award yeah the only one on
the team yeah but I got uh what is your
girl who can come what is it think girl
who either can't laughs or girl who
can't or gay
I'd say can't orgasm because I think she
can find other fun ways to get that
excitement and energy out of her body do
art maybe do some art some face paint
yeah face paint paint yourself up like a
gorilla you know yeah or a cat
that's ain't kindergarten or whatever
[ __ ] man
well your Tourette's is crazy I would go
with I don't care if a girl kit laughs
I'm gonna try my video my girl I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't need her to laugh
just busting nuts bro busting nuts and
she'll the grand ol time
you're disgusting dude I am yeah dude
you've a mirror you're the Glenn [ __ ]
what is a big baby a [ __ ] bro love
that putter for a dick it's a big deal I
have [ __ ] on that sand trap style you
feel me ally
on that [ __ ] I got that thick whistle
yeah born frog down there dude if you
drop my dick on a some it makes it sound
let your tugboat yeah all right well but
here's what I'm saying that's really
important is this dude please you're a
[ __ ] idiot please say something
important okay what is this lady asking
about girl you god dammit remember the
song
I've secondhand CT you've done nothing
no CT from the Sun if CT just from
walking outside from the Sun whatever
did you shake my hand pretty hard
sometimes here I'm saying is this girl
you have to have a woman that can laugh
laughter is important you know laughter
is really orgasm of your soul you know
I'm saying it's just straight coming out
of its science basically sound calm
preach and it's uh if you can make
somebody just shake and make a noise at
the same time that's what laughter it
yeah but also your friends you know
laughter and orgasm the same thing you
shake and make a noise alright fair
point what are you talking about the up
top gasm then that's laughter you
talking with that low gasm then that's
you know uh you know body you know
organs that penthouse where doesn't want
that basement does yeah right what do
you want I like that penthouse myself do
you yeah top yeah I'm going with
laughter now just so you convince me
otherwise
yeah okay well 64% people said never
orgasm mm-hmm because we're
[Music]
nothing
[Music]